[Applause]
[Music]
what it
do everybody my name is ross panetta
chef and owner of five kitchen and today
we're here to try
four celebrity steak recipes on today's
lineup we have
chrissy teigen aisha curry anthony
porowski
and the man the myth and the idiot
sandwich
gordon ramsay i measured out all the
ingredients as each recipe stated
and i brought three people on stakeouts
to see which one is their favorite steak
so which celebrity makes the best steak
stay tuned and find out
so first off we've got chrissy teigen
we're gonna start off by heavily
seasoning your steak with salt and
pepper
heavy emphasis on the pepper because
we're making steak all puave
in a pan we're gonna throw in some olive
oil and butter and heat it up
we're gonna saute our sliced button
mushrooms and season it with salt and
pepper
once they get a little bit of color
we're gonna throw some chicken stock and
butter
and reduce that once it's reduced we're
gonna add some more butter
season it with soy sauce and then finish
it up with some heavy cream
reduce that till it gets nice and thick
thick with two seeds
in a cast iron pan we're gonna to
hardtail our steak throw in some butter
garlic thyme we're going to baste that
once the steak is done we're going to
slice it up achieve a nice little medium
rare
plate it up and top it off with mushroom
gravy there you have it chrissy teigen
steak up 12 with mushroom gravy
looking pretty good okay i definitely
like what i'm seeing here this looks
yummy
we've got a nice looks like a peppered
crust
i like the mushrooms on top big fan
oh that's so good this is very good i
like the soft feel
when i bite down into it it's perfectly
textured i mean it's so soft
mushrooms have great flavor it's nice
and saucy
but not too much the peppered crust is a
really really nice touch it's got a nice
you know crispiness on the top i feel
like it's a little homemade
definitely tastes good though i think
you would find a steak like this
you know really nice restaurant i would
order this so next up we have aisha
curry's filet mignon we're going to
start off by seasoning our steak
with salt and pepper we're going to have
our miso plots we're going to have some
rosemary and garlic
in a cast iron pan we're going to sear
pretty hard until we get nice color on
both sides
we're going to throw in our butter and
rosemary we're going to base that really
quickly and then we're going to finish
it off in the oven at 475 degrees until
just medium rare once it comes out the
oven we're going to slice it up
and plate it and there you have it aisha
curry's oven baked filet mignon
i have a feeling this is going to be
really delicious and i'm really excited
to eat it
this smells really good i could really
smell the meat i do like
the color it does feel a little soft
this one definitely looks a little more
plain than the last one that i ate but
looks can be deceiving
there's nothing wrong with it it's plain
it's a little blend not feeling this one
guys
not feeling this one super tender
perfect texture it's a little tougher
than the last one i will say that but i
kind of like it it's cooked really well
i have no complaints overall bland so
here we have antioporovsky steak recipe
we're going to start off by making
shallow vinaigrette by thinly slicing
some shallots
throwing in a bowl and mixing it up with
the juice of one lime and season with a
little bit of salt and pepper
so anthony marinates the steak with some
crushed garlic and some thinly sliced
ginger
in a bowl we're going to put the ginger
and garlic and mix it with olive oil
and thoroughly marinate the hanger steak
for about a half hour
while that's marinating we're going to
chop up our herbs and our jalapeno for
garnish
we're going to ship a nod parsley basil
and mint and throw it in a bowl
along with some thinly sliced jalapenos
once the steak has been done marinating
we're going to wipe off as much of the
marinade as possible
season it with salt and pepper and give
that a nice hard sear
he throws in two halves of lime in the
pan for a little extra flavor
once the hanger steak is cooked we're
going to let it rest and we're going to
slice it up and plate
on the plate he tops it off with the
shallow vinaigrette the herbs jalapenos
and the juice of the two roasted limes
there you have it anthony perowski's
hanger steak
this one looks delicious it looks like
maybe a carne asada
something you would get at a taqueria
this is very yummy
it has a little kick okay it just tastes
super light and fresh it's truly
delicious
it's cooked perfectly definitely my kind
of
cut i love rare and i love medium rare
but i'm not digging
the flavor this is something i would
expect to probably be served at a
restaurant and it's got solid
ingredients
and it looks really good i'm married to
this steak
and i would eat this every single day if
i didn't
already have high cholesterol and the
recipe we've all been waiting for
gordon ramsay he's gonna start off by
seasoning his steak evenly with salt and
pepper
we're gonna heat up some olive oil in
our cast iron pan we're gonna give that
stick a nice sear
and we're gonna crush up some garlic
throw in some butter and baste it with
some thyme
just look at that magic once the steak
has achieved a nice rare
we're gonna slice it up and plate it and
as simple as that gordon ramsay's steak
okay okay i'm loving the smell i love
the fat pieces
this also looks plain but it looks like
a good piece of meat and i could see the
seasoning on it so it looks yummy
this one is definitely on the rare side
i'm a little nervous here but
i'm gonna go for it anyway i love the
mixture of fat
versus actual meat pieces it's super
soft
i wish there was a bit more of like a
punch of flavor but it's really good
this one has an amazing texture if
you're like a steak person you're
probably really gonna like this for me
i like my steak with a little more
pizzazz like give me some salt give me
some pepper i don't know
it's just a little plain it is a little
dry i wish it was juicy
but the flavor is there i'm digging that
i feel like i would be
served this cut at a restaurant i do
wish it had a little bit more flavor
so which celebrity has the best steak
let's find out
so out of these four celebrity steak
recipes i've gotta say that number three
was definitely my favorite
i loved the pickled onions i love the
jalapeno it just added that extra kick
and it was
delicious that guy i don't know who he
is
oh the guy from queer eye out of these
four celebrity
steak recipes my favorite has to be
number four i felt the flavor
the taste was there for me i liked how
it was cooked
gordon ramsay that's my dude my favorite
out of these four dishes was number
three it tasted
super fresh it was really nice and
tender
i loved everything about it and i would
easily want to eat it again
oh anthony my goodness
so i guess the judges enjoyed their
steaks makeover because anthony porowski
takes today's celebrity
steak challenge so which of these
celebrity recipes was your favorite
leave a comment below
[Music]
you